all right let's now go to the next
incident from yesterday's press briefing
even though the u.s and parts of the
world
have been dealing with supply chain
issues and shortages
delayed shipping times since the start
of the pandemic in march april of 2020.
that's been going on now for over a year
year and a half
the right now
is blaming joe biden's transportation
secretary pete budej because he's out on
paternity leave and not fixing the
problem which i guess is what they
believe he should be doing
this all came to a humiliating climax
yesterday during the very same white
house press briefing that we've been
talking about today uh gensake fielding
a question from newsmax reporter emerald
robinson emerald robinson cited a poll i
wasn't able to find which supposedly
says 65 percent of americans
believe pete buddha judge should get
back to work
he's on paternity leave he has premature
twins that he's uh uh
raising
and jen saki responded he is at work i
mean i had a phone call with him today
let's take a look at the clip and then
we're going to discuss paul found that
65 of voters think that given what's
going on he should come back to work
he's at work
he's on fraternity leave uh i was on a
conference call with him this morning
[Laughter]
he's and he's in the department now
every day
listen emerald i think what you're
getting at here is this question about
whether uh men parents uh women should
have paternity and maternity leave and
the answer is absolutely yes oh god in
our view that is the policy of this
administration that is what we're
pressing to make law so it's a reality
for women parents fathers
across the country and we're not going
to back away from that so there are so
many things to talk about here now of
course the truth is
the entire pete buddha judge thing is
it's hypocritical
it's ignorant to some degree
you can argue it's sexist in the sense
that paternity leave is seen differently
than maternity leave by many on the
right and maybe some on the left as well
but certainly by many on the right and
it's sort of thinly veiled or maybe not
so thinly veiled homophobia it's both
sexist and homophobic actually with
regards to buddha judge so let's let's
go through it it's hypocritical because
first of all
when donald trump was president
and elaine chao mitch mcconnell's wife
was the transportation secretary and
there were shortages during the pandemic
runs on toilet paper
canned goods
pasta or pasta as some of our friends in
the uk like to say everything
no one was claiming that elaine chao was
responsible in fact nobody even
mentioned elaine chow during that time
so that's the hypocrisy
if we it's ignorant because
they seem to think we have a system
where the supply chain and
transportation infrastructure depends on
one guy and if that guy's out because he
had twins everything breaks down if that
were the case it's an absurd system for
a country of 331 million people it would
be a pathetic system it's not the entire
supply chain system doesn't depend on p
buddha judge okay
next
it is um sexist because
very often
paternity leave is simply not taken as
seriously as maternity leave sometimes
it's as simple as who has the breasts
it's not the guy okay so paternity leave
is somehow less legitimate uh we know
outcomes are better for kids when they
are spending time with parents early you
know all these different things we know
but there's still this degree to which
paternity leave is just not taken as
seriously it's a form of sexism it's not
reverse sexism i don't use terms like
reverse sexism or reverse racism is it
sexist is it interpreted differently
merely because it's a father rather than
a mother yes that's that's the case
and it's also
slightly veiled homophobia
because what made people start focusing
on mayor pete to begin with mayor pete
uh
and his um husband chaston chaston a gay
couple that have adopted twins
what the focus uh the focus started on
mayor pete
because tucker carlson did this
disgusting segment where he said mayor
pete's on paternity leave what is he
learning how to breastfeed and it's
about the feminization of gay men
uh et cetera et cetera gay men want to
be women so p buddha judge would be
trying to breastfeed etc um and then
lastly you know as jen saki says
he's not even really fully off right
he's working remotely to some degree
he's having meetings you could argue
that's bad you could argue really he
should be able to be completely off on
paternity leave we do have a deputy
secretary of transportation we've got an
under secretary of transportation all of
this nonsense about the war on christmas
toy delays shipping delays supply chain
buddha judge
it's really all meant to be an attack on
joe biden for things they never
criticize trump over that's the big
picture they seems it seems they don't
realize buddha judge is actually doing
some work anyway but then you've got all
of the other stuff wrapped in with it
the sexism
uh the homophobia the ignorance
the false belief that the country's
supply chain and logistics
infrastructure depends on one guy
um and uh jen saki
she went with one approach which is he's
not really even fully on vacation like
he was on a call today and that's like a
counterfactual but there's all of this
other stuff that's wrapped up and
implicit in emerald robinson's question
and then by the way lastly
she said emerald
65 percent of americans say buddha judge
should be back to work the opinion of
americans about pete buddha judge's
paternity leave is sort of irrelevant
but i i looked i couldn't find that poll
maybe the poll exists maybe it's a poll
like of people who visit the newsmax
website i don't know
but i was able to find no evidence that
that poll actually exists so who knows
what that's even based on we'll have
more clips from this press briefing on
our instagram make sure you're following
us there at david pakman show
and follow us on tick tock at david
pakman show where we just hit 1 million
likes a completely arbitrary round
number of likes which is why i mention
it to you today